مشاركات المنتخبات الافريقيه في كاس
العالم لا تخلو من الكوميديا او ربما من
بعض التمرد ففي عام 74 هدد رئيس زائير
لاعبي المنتخب بعدم دخول البلاد اذا هزموا
من البرازيل باكثر من اربعه اهداف ولحسن
الحظ احرزت البرازيل في مرمى زائير ثلاثه
اهداف فقط اما في مونديال 2006 فرفض
لاعبوا منتخب توغو واللعب الا بعد الحصول
على مستحقاتهم ومنها نحو ثلاثين الف يورو
عند المكتب الا انهم هزموا في مبارياتهم
الثلاث وفي كاس العالم 2014 رفض لاعب
منتخب غانا اللعب بنفس السبب لكن الحكومه
الغنيه ارسلت لهم طائره خاصه تحمل ثلاثه
ملايين دولار نقدا وفي مونديال قطر طرد
المدرب سونج حارس الكاميرون من معسكر
الفريق بسبب ما قال مدربه انه فلسفه زائده
امام المرمى خلال التدريبات